[Music]
oh hey you know Capcom's stuff with my
Cry series sure knows how to have a good
time with its emphasis on stylish action
and an era Fraga doshas charm it's
become an endearing cornerstone in
Capcom's iconic library of games over
the course of its 18 year history the
series reveling in hyper stylized and
complex combat which set a new standard
for action games upon its first release
inspiring other developers to step up in
turn and pushing Capcom to evolve
further with the upcoming release of
Devil May Cry 5 we're taking a look back
at the series detailing its unexpected
beginnings and recounting how it became
the exuberant crazy and immensely
satisfying action franchise it is today
this is the history of Devil May Cry
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Devil May Cry Capcom's Devil May Cry
series is a name that's synonymous with
fast hack and slash gameplay that
marches to the beat of its own drum
however the series that would be devil
may cry originally began its life as
something quite different following the
massive success of Resident Evil 2 in
1998 which pushed Capcom to fast-track
work on resident evil 3 nemesis series
creator Shinji Mikami drafted plans for
the next major game in the survival
horror franchise Resident Evil 2
director Hideki Kamiya was tapped to
helmed the new project bringing the
series to the PlayStation 2 internally
Kamiya made a name for himself through
his passionate and uncompromising
approach to game design often
emphasizing challenging gameplay with
his experience and Punk personality
producers were confident he'd bring a
fresh change to the series while details
are scarce Kamiya's project was the
earliest incarnation of a Resident Evil
4 and featured a new protagonist named
Tony who possessed supernatural powers
similar to series antagonist Albert
Wesker although still a horror game
there was also a greater emphasis placed
on action-oriented gameplay this
prompted the shift away from the series
2d pre-rendered backgrounds to a new
perspective using a dynamic camera
system for 3d space after an extended
time in production Shinji Mikami and
other members of Capcom felt that the
game had strayed too far for Resident
Evil's roots but instead of scrapping
the work altogether they made the
decision to rework it into a new IP no
longer tied to the Resident Evil name
the developers rebranding themselves
internally as team little devils leaned
further into the action horror angles in
an interview with electronic gaming
monthly Kamiya stated that he did some
internal play testing on Onimusha
warlords another game with roots and
resin evil while laying the groundwork
for his game during his playthrough he
noticed a strange bug that allowed him
to juggle enemies with the character's
attacks this greatly amused the director
and he incorporated it into the new
game's mechanics instead of Resident
Evil's familiar monsters the new game
would feature demons of all shapes and
sizes some of whom towered over the main
character the style of combat also took
some cues from class
Hong Kong martial arts films
particularly in how to stage an action
scene Kamiya took particular inspiration
for the characterization of Dante from
the classic anime manga series space
adventure Cobra which starred a
swashbuckling interstellar adventurer
possessing a devil-may-care attitude to
pay homage to Dante Alighieri is
timeless poem the Divine Comedy which
saw its protagonists travel through the
many realms of hell the lead character
Tony was renamed Dante with a brand new
style and framework set they eventually
dubbed their new approach to gameplay as
stylish action a heavy freeform and
open-ended take on combat because it was
one of Capcom's early ps2 titles the
publisher put a lot of effort into the
game's marketing which included some
humorous takes on Dante style of combat
with considerable hype surrounding the
game following ìiî 2001 the new IP would
go on to make a sizable impression on
first-time players
Devil May Cry would release on August
23rd 2001 in Japan for the ps2 with the
US and PAL regions coming shortly after
as the half-demon half-human son of the
legendary Dark Knight Sparta the devil
hunting bounty hunter dante takes on
numerous jobs battling monsters and
otherworldly phos Devil May Cry sorry we
closed at night
again no password I can't seem to get
any room while in between gigs at his
headquarters named well Devil May Cry a
mysterious femme fatale named Trish
seeks the son of Sparta for a dangerous
job what follows is an incredibly
over-the-top exposition seen loaded to
the brim with crazy action perfectly
setting the tone for what's to come
[Music]
sword time to go to work guys
over the course of the game dante faces
off against hordes of demons controlled
by the Prince of Darkness mundis players
will gradually uncover more details
about Dante's past while also seeing the
true extent of his demonic abilities the
devil hunter also squares off with the
hell knight known as nello Angelo who
proves to be a formidable match for
Dante starting out with his twin
handguns ebony and ivory and with his
father's sword force edge dante expanses
our sum of weapons to include a
sawed-off shotgun and several devil arms
weapons of demonic origin in addition to
the Ifrit frame gauntlets he'll acquire
the lightning sword Aleister first
introduced in one of the game's more
gruesome scenes
[Music]
though mechanically it's far removed
from Resident Evil some echoes of that
series formula remains backtracking in
light puzzle-solving were present
propping players to make some extended
treks to unlock new areas of the castle
while it still invokes an eerie dread
inducing atmosphere similar to its
distant cousin Devil May cry's
rock-and-roll approach to horror
presented a pulsating contrast to the
foreboding tone running at a solid 60
frames per second this would be the
standard for most of the series which
allowed players to stay in tune with the
pacing at all times by locking onto
enemies Dante could trade off in between
long range and melee attacks with ease
allowing him to pull off slick maneuvers
such as launching foes in the air and
blowing them apart with a close-range
shotgun blast this was the core aspect
of the stylish action that the creators
were going for instead of playing it
safe and reacting the enemies Devil May
Cry expected players to act aggressively
and to switch up their tactics when the
situation called for it in doing so
players could engage with the freeform
flow of combat dynamically coming up
with their own styles of play
moreover all moves performed in combat
were graded getting hit or repeating the
same moves would lower this style
ranking but if you kept a steady flow
going and switched up moves on the
regular you would obtain the ever
elusive stylish rank and earn extra orbs
which could be used to upgrade Dante's
abilities though the early missions
actively empowered players by throwing
common foes their way these
show-stopping boss fights proved to be
battles too tough for many the first
encounter with phantom a lava-spewing
scorpion / spider hybrid demon because
why not proved to be a major hurdle for
players this fight would set the ground
rules for all boss fights going forward
including the final confrontation with
mundus at the game's end well double
make cry can be hammy throughout even
during some intense encounters there are
some key moments where the story steps
into dramatic territory leading to some
touching if mostly melodramatic moments
[Music]
after completing Devil May Cry the
harder difficulty settings unlock in the
mode aptly named Dante must die all
enemies have access to the Devil Trigger
mechanic greatly boosting their strength
and after that the legendary Dark Knight
mode is unlocked letting players swap
Dante out for his father Sparta who
presents himself in a far more regal
manner upon his release Devil May Cry
would receive strong praise from fans
and press alike in game spots review the
game was lauded for its fast-paced and
challenging gameplay proving itself to
be a must-have for PlayStation owners
the game immediately had strong sales
and quickly found its way onto the
PlayStation Tuesday list of greatest
hits
DMC 1 was especially a hit for hardcore
players fans online began to share tips
and videos of their best performances
akin to the community surrounding
fighting games like Street Fighter since
this was before the launch of YouTube
and other dedicated video sites the
actual sharing of these videos mostly
took place on online messaging forums
and custom sites like geo cities giving
the hardcore DMC fanbase and underground
mystique around the time of Devil May
Cry one's release in 2001 the producers
at Capcom could sense they had a hit on
their hands with the new IP not wanting
to waste an opportunity they immediately
began work on Devil May Cry 2 with an
entirely different team the original
team would learn of the sequels
existence after the fact which created
some friction internally this would
eventually be the spark for Kamiya and
team little devils to form something new
but more on that later
with an expected release in early 2003
little more than a year after the launch
the original the DMC 2 team was under a
lot of pressure according to series
creator Hideki Kamiya who is very candid
about his past experiences with Capcom
the sequel was in crisis with only 5
months before launch producers replaced
the original director of DMC 2 with
veteran developer Hideo ki its uno whose
past work included fighting games such
as the Street Fighter Alpha series and
rival schools with the release window
firm the new director had to Shepard the
game to the finish
Devil May Cry 2 would hit its launch
date on January 23rd 2003 for the
PlayStation 2 in the US with the Japan
and PAL versions arriving soon after
[Music]
Devil May Cry two players would once
again control Dante set several years
after the original now older and a bit
more reserved than in the original game
he comes into conflict with arias the
president of the corporation Ouroboros
seeking for demonic artifacts to grant
himself immense power the villain
planned to summon forth a powerful demon
in order to take over the world
[Music]
the mc2 included a second protagonist in
the form of luca another femme fatale
with demonic powers of her own
the sequel also featured two distinct
campaigns for both characters on their
own separate discs though DMC two had a
great deal of hype surrounding its
release the final product would receive
heavy criticism for regression from the
original one particular point of
contention was Dante's personality with
the devil hunter only occasionally
dropping one-liners which felt very out
of character looks like it's your lucky
day
wonderful I am very pleased over the
course of Devil May Cry to spare allall
stories Dante would learn more about
Sparta's lasting influence and Luca
would come to understand the truth about
her past just like in the original game
the protagonist would gradually in cover
new weapons and confront several bosses
of varying sizes
while both Dante and Lucas stories would
each cover the same ground both
characters had special encounters unique
to their campaigns
going for a more streamlined and
scaled-down approach DMC 2's combat made
a number of changes the playable
characters possessed all their unique
combat abilities from the beginning and
upgrading weapons only slightly increase
attack strength the game did introduce a
new amulet system which tried to fill in
that gap for customizing play styles
which amplified Dante and Lucas Devil
Trigger States with enhanced abilities
movement and attacks were also
overhauled for easier access to key
moves and an increased focus on
verticality and agility the protagonists
could wall run and shoot upside down in
midair at the enemies below and even
swap weapons mid combo allowing for some
extra finesse during fights
however the sequel removed many of the
originals more iconic attacks such as
the million stab in response to players
surveys taken after the first game's
release this equals difficulty was
significantly dial down this was
intended to let players pick up the game
without frustration but the end result
was a game that made combat encounters
far too easy letting players rinse and
repeat attacks without much worry from
the enemies or the overly forgiving of
style rankings though Devil May Cry 2
featured questionable design choices it
still possessed some welcomed
innovations in addition to a mission
select and weapon swapping a new mode
called bloody Palace would open up
letting players fight waves of enemies
through a lengthy dungeon these features
would eventually go on to become the
game's more worthwhile contributions to
the series
though Devil May Cry 2 was a popular
seller it fared poorly when it came to
critics and general audience reaction
GameSpot scored the game a six point
four and stated in its review that the
downgraded gameplay and presentation
made it a disappointing sequel DMC 2 is
generally seen as the black sheep of the
series the developers don't view the
game very favorably either with the
sequels that came after largely ignoring
it
despite the series poor reputation the
series of stuff would still remain
popular after DMC 2's release Dante even
found his way into non video game media
including a North American comic series
and a 2003 manga which dealt with the
events before the first game after DMC 1
and with the sequel under way without
them creator Hideki Kamiya and team
little devils collectively began work on
a new IP that took some inspiration from
their past work they channeled that
energy into something that took a far
more stylized
and cinematic approach but we'll save
that for its own episode maybe Kamiya
and the other creatives would use
beautiful Joe as a launch pad to form a
new dev team within Capcom known as
clover studio although only actor for
four years they released well beloved
titles such as God hand in Okami
all of which were informed by their work
on Devil May Cry the first official
release under the clover name would be
the ps2 port of beautiful Joe although
largely the same game the version
included DMC ones Dante as an unlockable
character Dante and Trish would replace
the two leads prompting the bounty
hunter to fight his way through the
movie role using his unique skillset
in one of Dante's most unique
appearances he found his way into the
2004 release of atlases JRPG Shin Megami
Tensei Nocturne this collaboration
happened as a suggestion from one of the
developers who was a fan of Devil May
Cry set in the post-apocalyptic ruins of
demon infested Shinjuku Japan the devil
hunter actively tailed the game's lead
character during the journey as the
first SMT game released in the West
Atlas wanted to create some additional
buzz for the game's launch which they
also made very very very clear on the
game's box art sets DMC's debuted there
was a notable resurgence in action games
from other developers many of whom cited
the series as a big influence the
creators of God of War regularly
mentioned Devil May Cry as an
inspiration for the game's combat
although DMC 2 wasn't the sequel that
publisher Capcom hoped for it ultimately
paved the way for the series return to
form revealed at e3 2004 Devil May Cry 3
Dante's Awakening was the next game in
the series
[Music]
as a prequel it focused on Dante's
younger more rebellious years while also
revealing his past feud with his twin
brother Virgil in the original Devil May
Cry it was revealed that the boss anello
Angelo was actually Virgil whom had been
corrupted by Mundus kaitiaki at suno
would return to direct Dante's awakening
in the lead-up to the release he stated
that he wanted to do the series proper
justice while also expanding upon the
story and sense of style during a Devil
May Cry panel at PAX West 2018 suno
would refer to the particular style he
brought to the series as tune in Avoca
ng these same exuberance and sense of
fun that's commonly associated with
anime in action films a stronger focus
on story allowed the team to also dial
up the excess and bravado from the
original game so the developers sought
performers that could bring physicality
and charisma to their roles casting both
Rueben Langdon and Daniel south worst
for Dante and Vergil respectively they
provided voiceovers and motion capture
for the games cutscenes this approach
would go on to set a new standard for
Capcom's Triple A games significantly
improving the quality of presentation
for their games moving forward released
on February 17 2005 in Japan with the
u.s. launch on March 22nd 2005 Devil May
Cry 3 Dante's awakening would prove to
be the rebirth that the series needed
I met the sons of Sparta both of them
though the same blood of their father
flowed through their veins the two
battled each other fiercely like
archenemies
it seemed as if they derived some sort
of twisted pleasure from this brotherly
fighting
[Music]
sorry not open for business yet
Mearing the opening of the original game
the up-and-coming devil hunter dante is
visited by the agnatic arkham a human
with a keen interest in demons and the
legend of sparta arkham also reveals
that he is working with Dante's brother
Virgil and the demon soon begin to take
over the city after fighting off
monsters who've broken into his office a
massive tower forms in the center of the
city no doubt you've got some fun
planned for me right Virgil
Dante sets out to find his brother and
eventually encounters other powerful
demons and another human referred to as
lady who is seeking revenge against her
father Arkham
[Music]
[Music]
Here I am trying to help you and you
show your thanks by shooting me
eventually the twins would faceoff to
decide who is the rightful heir to
Sparta's legacy this is what they call
us
[Music]
and dmc3 dante is given more dramatic
presents to counterbalance his familiar
wisecracking antics a heightened sense
of style would also shop at the games
new suite of weapons including the
talking twin swords and the incredibly
bizarre yet strangely appropriate
lightning guitar slash scythe hybrid
with an expanded arsenal Dante could
customize his loadouts with the various
upgrade statues throughout the game
switching weapons returned from DMC to
now working for both ranged and melee
combat holding up to two melee weapons
and two firearms
players could deck out Dante in any way
they saw fit letting Dante swap tactics
and skills mid combo while maintaining a
stylish flow after your first
confrontation with Virgil Dante as the
subtitle clearly states will awake into
his inner Devil Trigger ability
depending on which weapon he wields
while in his Devil Trigger state Dante's
appearance will alter to fit the style
of the melee weapon both Dante and
Vergil Devil triggers were designed by
Atlas designer Kazuma koneko who Capcom
collaborated on with Nocturne venturing
slightly into RPG territory DMC 3
introduced a new mechanic known as the
style system players could select from
six different combat styles which
focused on different facets of Dante's
skills the sword master more on melee
combat abilities the trickster on dodges
and teleports gunslinger opened up new
firearm skills Royal Guard allowed Dante
to parry attacks Quicksilver gave the
devil hunter the ability to stop time
and doppelganger led Dante create a
shadow clone of himself using one style
for extended periods leveled it up
increasing the Styles effectiveness in
order to satisfy hardcore players of the
series in the West capcom made these
somewhat misguided decision to calibrate
the difficulties between different
releases with the original DMC 3 the
hard mode version for the japanese
version was made the normal version for
the western release this unfortunately
ended up alienating many players who
struggle with the game's challenge
[Music]
within each of us flows his blood
more portly his soul
[Music]
see he wants to stop you
unfortunately our souls are at odds
brother
I need
Devil May Cry 3 Dante's awakening would
release two strong reviews from critics
although the initial sales faltered when
compared to the previous games
many fans sought as a return to form in
GameSpot's review the expanded combat
was praised however the difficulty was
criticized for being unfair
Devil May Cry free would become the
first game in the series to seen updated
release with Devil May Cry 3 special
edition releasing as a ps2 Greatest Hits
title in the West this version of the
game rebalance of difficulty settings
added new boss encounters with the
puckish jester and reintroduced DMC
two's bloody palace furthermore a new
turbo mode was also introduced doubling
the game speed however the special
editions most exciting feature was the
playable Virgil
though he goes through the exact same
levels as Dante and strangely enough
battles his doppelganger during the
virgil boss fights new cutscenes were
added to show more of his side to the
story after Devil May Cry freeze release
the series would eventually receive an
anime series of its own with Ruben
Langdon reprising his role as Dante
coming from madhouse the same studio
behind Death Note gun grave and try gun
this series was set after the events of
DMC 1 focusing on Dante and close allies
taking on various missions dealing with
demons and the occult in incredibly
over-the-top fashion but with the new
generation of consoles approaching
Capcom made plans to ensure that their
series would be ready to make the jump
at e3 2005 only a few months after DMC
threes launched Devil May Cry 4 was
announced as a PlayStation 3 exclusive
with the Xbox 360 also set to release
later that year capcom would capitalize
on the new platform by developing a new
slate of IPs geared toward a western
audience these titles were Dead Rising
and Lost Planet both of which utilized
Capcom's next-gen engine MT framework
the series producers also saw an
opportunity to expand DMC even further
in 2007 just a year before its launch it
was announced that DMC 4 would release
simultaneously for the Xbox 360 and
PlayStation 3 this decision was made as
a result of this success the developers
had with the 360 and also due to the
rising challenges associated with the
ps3 cel processor infrastructure the
news of the series going multi-platform
was met with heavy criticism from
longtime fan
who work comfortable with a series once
dedicated to the PlayStation platform
releasing elsewhere
Hettie aki @ sunnah would once again
direct the next Devil May Cry game
though dante would return for the new
entry the developers also wanted to
switch things up this came in the form
of a new protagonist possessing a
different play style giving newcomers a
solid entry point for the series
Nero's demonic devil bringer allowed him
to grapple enemies up close
also his sword known as the Red Queen
just so happened to have a motorcycle
handle on it which can be revved up to
power his attacks portrayed by Johnny
Yong Bosch who played Vash the Stampede
and Trigon Ichigo and bleach and was
also a former power ranger Nero brought
a particular swagger and youthful
exuberance that made him an interesting
contrast to Dante in the year's census
launch the developers have stated that
work on the game was a challenging
process due to rapid changes in
technology narrative writer bingo Mori
Hoshi stated in an interview and The
Devil May Cry 3 1 for 2 graphics art
book that due to poor communication and
limited manpower many ideas couldn't
make the cut several of these concepts
often related to Nero who actually had
other demonic forms at one point on
January 31st 2008 Devil May Cry 4 would
launch on the PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360
marking the series first release on new
consoles
[Music]
Devil May Cry 4 you start the game as
Nero a soldier in the order of the sword
on the island of Fortuna during a sermon
held by the high priest Sanctus
Dante attacks members of the Holy Order
and Nero faces off of the devil hunter
so you're looking to play huh all right
I guess I got some time to kill after
coming to an uneasy truce
Dante reveals that demons are among them
prompting Nero to find his own answers
throughout fortuna eventually his latent
demonic powers come to light revealing
abilities that proved to be a match for
even Dante but once things escalate out
of control the veteran devil hunter
takes the reins to clean up the mess
that's overtaken the island I'll sweep
the city and evacuate the people hey is
this your way of ditching and dumping
this message which it's cool let's stick
to the plan though Nero's play style was
far more limited when compared to the
versatility of Dante players could still
get a lot of mileage out of his devil
Berner skills and his melee attacks
eventually Nero would gain access to his
own devil trigger after requiring
Virgil's weapon from dmc3 when activated
Nero conjures forth a specter in the
form of Virgil's Devil sugar greatly
amplifying the strength and range of his
attacks though it's never stated
outright DMC for present strong hints
that Nero himself may have some relation
to the Sparta bloodline
during the midpoint of the game Dante
once again takes center stage
just like his outing in dmc3 he utilizes
the multi style system in combat but in
DMC for da taken swap styles in real
time in addition to utilizing all of his
weapons without having to choose a
loadout
though Dante's suite of weapons are
mostly familiar one new devil arm is the
Lucifer utilizing a fighting style
similar to a flamingo dance the Lucifer
fires out demonic shards that explodes
on command the weapon is first
introduced in a innuendo laced monologue
that gets extremely tongue-in-cheek very
quickly
[Music]
the Dante section featured some of the
game's biggest moments his half of the
game was heavily criticized for
excessive padding which many fans and
critics were disappointed by this
feeling of padding was epitomized in the
appearance of a strange dice game that
slowed the pace down considerably
[Music]
DMC 4 also added some new gameplay
moments outside of combat which included
new set-piece encounters similar to
moments in games like God of War in the
games most standout encounter Dante
battles a towering demonic statue in the
form of Sparta or crying the devil
hunter to leap across multiple platforms
to find his various weak points in
traditional fashion completing the game
would unlock the bloody palace mode and
access to the additional difficulty
modes including Dante must die two
additional modes were also added in the
form of Heaven and Hell and Helen hel
modes the former returning from DMC 3
was the hardest mode but with all the
enemies dying in one hit while the
latter would result in the protagonist
dying in one hit Devil May Cry 4 would
go on to receive solid reviews from the
press and fans alike in game spots
review it was praised for its impressive
combat but received heavy criticism for
the repetitive structure thanks to the
multi-platform launch DMC 4 would
eventually become the best-selling game
in the series which still stands to this
day our core fans of the series took a
strong liking to the game as well with
many stating that the gameplay of DMC 4
has the most sophisticated combat in the
series the game would also make its way
to the PC which delivered increased
performance and a new mode which
significantly increased the amount of
enemies on screen in the late 2000s and
early 2010's capcom began to undergo
some changes as a result to the shifting
landscape of the gaming market following
the release of DMC for many of the games
key staff felt fatigued and wanted to
move on to different projects director
Hideo ki at suno would go on to helm
Dragon's Dogma Capcom's ambitious
attempt at an open-world RPG
some key creatives who worked on the DMC
series left Capcom to form the new
studio PlatinumGames their first game
for the ps3 and xbox 360 would be the
action-adventure hack and slash
Bayonetta which was held by DMC one
director Hideki Kamiya Platinum Games
would go on to make more games in a
similar vein including Metal Gear Rising
revengeance and near automata the
original DMC trilogy would also see a
return with the 2012 release of the
Devil May Cry HD collection for the ps3
and 360 in 2018 the collection would
eventually be ported to the PC ps4 and
Xbox one still proving to be a popular
character Dante made an appearance in
Project X zone
they turned a strategy game mashing
together characters from Sega Capcom and
Bandai Namco libraries however his most
recognizable guest spot ever would be in
Marvel vs. Capcom 3 fate of two worlds
Dante and Trish joined the roster of
characters and they took part in the 3v3
battles that utilized the game's
tag-team systems in the enhanced version
Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3 Virgil was
also added to the roster despite all
these cameos Capcom had no immediate
plans for a sequel to DMC for Capcom's
former head of global production Keiji
Inafune a would push for more
collaborations with Western developers
along with new IPs such as Dark Void
producers even gave Western studios a
shot at their existing franchises
including Dead Rising Bionic Commando
and even Resident Evil the fans were
clamoring for a new Devil May Cry
however the next game barring that
particular name wasn't quite the game
they were expecting
is your
my name is Dante reveal that Tokyo Game
Show 2010 DMC Devil May Cry yes that is
with a lowercase M was a reimagining of
the series mythos developed by Ninja
Theory previously of Heavenly Sword and
enslaved Odyssey to the West Fame at the
initial reveal ninja theory and Capcom
presented the game as their most
ambitious collaborative effort yet
Capcom approached Ninja Theory because
of their experience with action games
that have a strong focus on narrative
and presentation unfortunately the
sudden reveal of a reboot for Devil May
Cry was met with controversy leading to
an incredibly toxic period for the
developers and community alike one of
the more vocal points of backlash was
the focus on the new characters design
particularly the lack of Dante's
familiar white hair throughout
development the Dante of DMC actually
went through a number of changes in
addition to some designs that resembled
Geralt from The Witcher 2 a quasi Jason
Statham look they also made concepts
that were fairly close to the classic
Dante
however Capcom and it's you know himself
stressed to the developers at ninja
theory that they should make DMC the way
they wanted to so in turn they created a
design that echoes that of the previous
incarnations while also standing out on
its own to add more weight to its new
narrative ninja theory consulted with 28
days later and sunshine screenwriter
Alex Garland who they had previously
worked with on enslaved Odyssey to the
west in the years since the game's
reveal several members of the dev team
stated that DMC was revealed too early
and on the wrong foot which only added
to the negativity from fans eager for
more information many of the more
intense criticisms from fans were levied
against the developers themselves often
citing the studio's average track record
on previous games fans also became upset
after learning that the game would run
at 30 frames per second on consoles a
noticeable step down from previous games
unfortunately the negativity would later
escalate into online threats and
harassment against the developers more
than two years after its reveal ninja
theories DMC Devil May Cry would
eventually release worldwide On January
15 2003 for the ps3 and xbox 360 with
the PC version On January 25th
get your filthy [ __ ] claw off my
trailer
missed the reboot starts off with Dante
now a half angel half demon being known
as a Nephilim enjoying a night out on
the town
not long after he's discovered by a
powerful demon known as the hunter who
seeks out the living descendants of
Sparta dante sooner nights with his
long-lost brother Virgil and they work
together with their human a like at and
a secret organization to overcome the
influence of the demon king Mundus DMC's
plot takes large influences from films
like John Carpenter's they live
presenting a story about two parallel
worlds in hidden conflict but with a
more youthful energy throughout in DMC
Dante is depicted as far more rebellious
in previous games and mundis is
presented as a demonic corporate
overlord whose weaponized late stage
capitalism to enslave humanity
[Music]
how do people actually fall for this
crap though ninja theories DMC has a
darker and more satirical plot than the
previous games it uses realistic topics
like debt and propaganda as a backdrop
for its action-oriented focus on hacking
and slashing demons there's still plenty
of moments of humor some of which break
the fourth wall and poke fun at the
controversy surrounding the game
[Music]
the combat of DMC takes a more flexible
approach from past games while still
referencing some of classic Dante's
iconic skills utilizing three weapon
styles the human demon and Angel forms
each have their own moves and unique
weapons tied to them swapping between
forms alters Dante's fighting style
dramatically leading to some impressive
combos that play into Dante's aerial
abilities and raw attack power
[Music]
some enemies were tuned to certain forms
which required players to stick with a
particular play style to counter them he
also possesses a special whip allowing
him to pull himself to enemies or yanked
them towards him and to reach platforms
that are a distance away from him
DMC places a larger emphasis on
environmental storytelling focusing
heavily on the fluctuating environments
that embodied the larger themes of the
game Dante would get pulled into the
demonic parallel reality known as limbo
showing off the distortion of the human
world while within the alternate realm
in one mission a popular nightclub in
the human world becomes a winding
nightmare gallery of neon lights and
pulsating rhythmic beats in limbo with
the ambient club noises and songs
reverberating throughout to create
physical platforms throughout the levels
[Music]
with music from both industrial metal
band combi cries and neuro funk group
Noisia DMC soundtrack is an eclectic
blend of heavy harsh beats with the
slick sounds of electronica infused into
the battles and key moments of the story
ninja Theory also included a rather
clever take on dynamic music with the
players actual performance in combat
actively amplifying the intensity of the
battle tracks if you manage to hit an
s-rank in battle the vocals from the
song would kick in
shortly after its launch Capcom released
the returning bloody palace mode along
with the DLC epilogue Virgil's downfall
and this expansion players take on the
role of Virgil shortly after his defeats
at the hands of Dante set entirely in
the demon world the ending of the mini
campaign shows Virgil's embracing his
inner darkness which teased what was to
come in a potential sequel
though still a polarizing game DMC Devil
May Cry received mostly favorable
reviews
however there were numerous criticisms
for the 360 and ps3 technical issues
such as the inconsistent frame rate
which were ultimately remedied for the
PC release in GameSpot's review DMC's
style and approach to combat was well
liked
although the technical shortcomings were
too common to overlook DMC Devil May Cry
didn't quite meet Capcom's lofty goals
however it still proved to be a solid
seller for all platforms particularly
the PC release which saw numerous player
mods defeat up at a slightly cycling era
in the years since its uno has praised
DMC Devil May Cry even stating in an
interview with Game Informer that it's
his favourites despite receiving flack
from fans the developers at Ninja Theory
enjoyed their time with the series
stating that DMC was their finest work
up until that point since the reboots
release Capcom had kept quiet on the
series however that silence broke in
2014 with the simultaneous announcements
of DMC definitive edition and Devil May
Cry 4 special edition ninja theories
returned for the definitive edition
yielded improvements to the existing
games mechanics in addition to adding in
the new hardcore mode which rebalance
the game and altered certain design
quirks it also greatly improved
performance that maintained a solid 60
frames per second this release while not
fixing every issue that fans had did go
on to receive a stronger reception from
both them and critics alike in Devil May
Cry 4 special edition Capcom and
co-developer access games added three
new playable characters to the game
along with the firearm focus lady and
the Sparta sword wielding Trish the
returning antagonist Virtua also made a
comeback
although Nero and Dante's campaign was
intact lady and Trish could also replace
both characters for their own story and
Virgil himself could experience the
entire campaign solo Dante would make
yet another appearance in the popular
crossover fighting game Marvel vs.
Capcom as a playable character in
infinite Dante was the lone character
from the series who made an appearance
however he still brought plenty of
weapons and his particular brand of
style that made him stand out in the
roster the status of the series remained
unknown after the release of both
enhanced edition
in 2015 still that didn't stop fans from
sharing their passion for the series
online with many combo exhibition videos
the continued pace of these videos would
further energize the DMC community
getting fans to organize their own
events online some of which were for
charity eventually rumors began to
spread online of a new DMC game and
development
dealing the return that many had been
hoping for
[Music]
[Music]
hey honey
the assistants
to hit every single bump in the road my
crew
reveal that III 2018 Devil May Cry 5 is
bringing back familiar faces such as
Dante Nero lady and Trish featuring a
campaign with three playable characters
including tu comer V DMC five channels
much of the series classic gameplay
while also adding more modern Flair that
gives it a look unlike any other in the
series set after Devil May Cry 4 the
next game will also mark the end of
these sons of Sparta storyline involving
Dante Nero
and the possibility of the reappearance
of Virgil with fans having expressed a
desire for the series to make a return
DMC 5 director Hideyoshi at suno took to
the stage during Microsoft's e3 press
conference and proudly stated the MC is
back set for launch on March 8 2019 DMC
5 will be the return that fans of the
series have been waiting 11 years for
the Devil May Cry series has made an
undeniable impact on the action genre
pressing its players to learn its
mechanics and be better while also
pushing Capcom itself to adapt to new
challenges on their own front the
franchise will also see another adaption
in a new Netflix animated series from
adi shankara producer behind the current
Castlevania series so we haven't heard
the end of DMC for quite some time as
the street fighter of the action genre
the series brand of stylish action is
iconic as it is endearing Capcom and
other developers like Platinum Games in
Sony Santa Monica with their recent God
of War II boot still carry the torch for
pure action games proving that the
spirit of Devil May Cry is still alive
and well thank you for watching this
episode of history of and special thank
you to Alessandro filari who wrote this
episode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]